[Music]
the greatest challenge of vampire hunter
can take on is to bring sunlight into a
vampire's lair
you've stealthily descended into the
darkness of a vampire cave setting a
sequence of mirrors as you go when the
Sun reaches the right angle in the sky a
focused beam of light will ricochet
along the mirrors strike your diffuser
and illuminate the great chamber where
the vampires sleep you set the final
mirror and sneak through an opening in
the corner of the great chamber the
diffuser must be wall-mounted but the
walls are crowded with coffins which you
don't dare disturb the only open spots
are in the other three corners of the
room the light will enter through the
southwest corner at a 45 degree angle
and bounce off the perfectly smooth
metallic walls until it hits one of the
other three corners but which corner
will it hit you know the room is a
rectangle 49 meters wide and 78 meters
long you could probably find the answer
by drawing a scale model of the room and
tracing the path of the light but the
Sun will be in its place in just minutes
and you've got no time to spare
fortunately there's a different way to
solve this puzzle that's both simple and
elegant so in which corner should you
place the diffuser to flood the vampire
lair with sunlight
[Music]
you could tackle this problem by
examining smaller rooms and you'd find a
lot of interesting patterns but there's
one insight that can unravel this riddle
in almost no time at all let's draw the
chamber on a coordinate grid with the
southwest corner at the point 0 0 the
light passes through grid points with
coordinates that are either both even or
both odd this is true even after it
bounces off one or more walls another
way of thinking about it is this since
the light travels at a 45 degree angle
it always crosses the diagonal of a unit
square traveling one meter horizontally
changes the x coordinate from even to
odd or vice versa traveling one meter
vertically changes the y coordinate from
even to odd or vice versa traveling
diagonally as the light does here does
both at once so the x and y coordinates
of any points the light passes through
must be both even or both odd this
observation is more powerful than it
seems in particular it means that we
have a way to identify the kinds of
points the light won't ever go through
if one of the coordinates is even and
the other is odd the light will miss
them that means it'll miss the top two
corners of the room since those points
have one even and one odd coordinate the
southeast corner is the only option for
the diffuser and indeed when that
precious beam of sunlight enters the
hall it bounces between the walls and
strikes the southeast corner spot on the
vampires sensing the intrusion bursts
from their coffins and turned to dust in
the light it was a high-stakes test and
you passed with flying colors you've
used your smarts to defeat the vampires
but can you take on a werewolf or
perhaps a family of giants check out
these riddles to test your wits
[Music]